[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi deux genres tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal
rien ne va plus à coignières le maire
jean-pierre sevestre n'a plus de
majorité au sein de son conseil
municipal en conséquence certaines
délibérations n'ont pas été adoptées
lors de la dernière séance ce vendredi
une assemblée sous tension où le mot
démission a été entendu à plusieurs
reprises un pique nique de soutien aux
migrants il s'est tenu hier devant le
centre de rétention administratif de
plaisir un rassemblement à l'appel du
collectif amis et qui regroupe une
trentaine d'associations des yvelines
objectif dénoncer les conditions de vie
à des personnes sur place
et puis il est disponible depuis
aujourd'hui un timbre spécial ryder cup
2018 a été émis par le groupe la poste
l'occasion de célébrer l'arrivée de la
plus grande compétition de golf à saint
quentin en yvelines pour en parler
frédéric morin directeur adjoint de
philaposte est notre invité dans cette
édition nous recevrons également gérard
bacheliers le président de la cci à
versailles yvelines la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie a inauguré lé
open spot 78 un espace à digital et de
coworking il n'avait pas pu se dérouler
le 19 juin dernier faute de place le
conseil municipal de coignières s'est
finalement tenue vendredi dernier dans
un espace plus grand à la maison de
voisinage salle comble et conseil sous
haute tension le maire jean-pierre
sevestre a été la cible de ses opposants
mais mis en difficulté également par sa
propre majorité
les détails avec ce sujet adoré les ans
m
désavoué par sa majorité le maire de
coignières jean-pierre sevestre n'a pas
pu faire voter les délibérations
concernant les comptes de gestion et
administratif 2010 est que conseil
municipal reportait le 19 juin dernier
faute d'accueil suffisant c'est une
nouvelle fois déroulé dans un climat
agité et divisé c'est la première fois
que j'entends une telle situation donc
je vais voir comment on peut s'y
maintenir je
vais soumettre donc le compte
administratif qui ont approuvé à la
sous-préfecture et puis voir
effectivement l'évolution des évolutions
des choses au cours des prochaines
semaines
depuis plusieurs mois rien ne va plus
entre le maire et son conseil
[Musique]
entre le projet de communes nouvelles
avec maurepas et des soupçons
d'irrégularités au sein de son équipe
jean-pierre sevestre a été pris à partie
le mot démission a été prononcée à
plusieurs reprises à commencer par
l'ancien maire de la ville
si le 1er septembre il n'a pas
démissionné sa vie va devenir infernal
certains voyaient dans notre pétition
disait qu'il fallait critiquer la ville
que je vais vous demandons la démission
de l'ensemble de son équipe
demandez ce qui reste autour de lui
aujourd'hui qui restitue à peu près un
tiers de conseil municipal
ça ça suffirait effectivement à
provoquer de nouvelles élections
le conseil municipal s'est terminée par
une mise en demeure à l'encontre de
jean-pierre sevestre puis d'un tiers des
membres demandent au maire de convoquer
un nouveau conseil avec 12 points
obligatoires
parmi eux l'élection d'un conseiller
communautaire à saint quentin en
yvelines ou encore le maintien du
deuxième adjoint ali bout slam dans ses
fonctions ali bousselham qui a
d'ailleurs porté plainte contre jean
pierre sevestre pour diffamation dans un
communiqué de presse le deuxième adjoint
l'accusent d'avoir je cite a terni sa
réputation et attenté à son honneur par
des allégations mensongères et notamment
sur l'antenne de tv 78 le 20 juin
dernier une petite correction comme
indiqué en début de journée elle ne
sommes pas le lundi 2 juin mais bien sûr
le lundi 2 juillet le lieu était
insolite est loin d'être idyllique ce
dimanche le réseau pour l'accueil des
migrants des yvelines organisé un pique
nique c'était devant le centre de
rétention administrative de plaisir
ce collectif qui rassemble une trentaine
d'associations du département dénonce
les conditions de vie sur place et les
différents manquements aux droits des
migrants pour eux le lieu est une prison
et déguisent
les précisions de nicolas landry et
nicolas kirillovitch organisé un pique
nique par beau temps avec plus de 30
degrés un dimanche midi
jusque là tout est normal choisir en
revanche un commissariat comme décor le
choix peut sembler étrange c'est pour
dénoncer les conditions de vie dans ce
centre de rétention administrative que
le réseau amis s'est réunie verre à la
main une trentaine de personnes sont
venues soutenir les migrants enfermé à
plaisir bien sûr qu'il faut qu'il y ait
des endroits dans lequel les jambes sont
en transit en attendant que la police
fasse son travail
mais il faut qu'il y ait un usage se
sentant des irritations qu'ils soient
modérés et pas comme actuellement
et puis que un certain nombre de mesures
soient prises pour que les mineurs ne
soit pas enfermé
ouvert en 2006 implanté dans le
commissariat le centre de rétention de
plaisir peut accueillir jusqu'à 26
personnes en même temps
les associations locales dénoncent
notamment le manque de personnel sur
place qui impacterait selon elle les
droits des étrangers
ça peut arriver par exemple que quinze
jours fériés ont refusé à une famille de
voir son fiancé son fils son mari son
père enfin la personne qui est où sa
soeur ou sa femme
donc tu as de ce point de vue là il ya
il ya un non respect du droit des gens
les personnes qui sont dans ce centre ne
sont pas condamnés elles n'ont commis
aucun délit en france en 2016 près de
45000 personnes ont été placés en centre
de rétention administrative
le projet de loisy l'émigration prévoit
un allongement de la durée maximale de
rétention de 45 à 90 jours le lieu a été
inaugurée il ya une semaine la cci
versailles yvelines chambre de commerce
et d'industrie s'est dotée de l'open
spot 78 et gérard bacheliers est avec
nous en plateau pour en parler bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la cci
versailles yvelines alors open spot 78,7
un espace de coworking espace partagé de
travail en espace et digital également
c'est une offre qu'on voit se développer
dans plusieurs cci
ile de france pourquoi la proposer dans
les yvelines c'est ça se développe dans
toutes les cci d'île de france et
pourquoi la proposer dans les villes
parce qu'il ya des besoins aussi des
espaces de coworking et des espaces
aussi de charbon pour présenter des
solutions nouvelles des solutions
numériques
donc il fallait également que l'on ait
cet espace sur versailles et que l'on
puisse justement au pouvoir à la fois
partager un espace de coworking
accueillir accueillir des entreprises et
créateurs d'entreprises des personnes
qui souhaitent justement travailler dans
un espace de coworking aussi leur donner
la possibilité d'accéder à des
conseillers de la chambre qui seront là
juste à côté d'eux on est justement un
tournant depuis plusieurs années celui
du numérique du digital pourquoi c'est
primordial aujourd'hui pour les
entreprises de ne pas rater ce wagon
pourquoi il faut entamer cette
transformation digitale de l'entrejeu
crois que ça fait pas mal d'années que
c'est essentiel pour les entreprises
qu'elles doivent justement se développer
avec le digital ce que nous avions déjà
mis en place à la chambre de commerce de
versailles yvelines à partir de 2006
était justement des opérations qui
permettait à des entreprises d'accéder
au digital avec des financements à
l'époque du conseil général mais nous
continuer nous continuons justement avec
des plans de dd plan de financement
intéressant qui permettent justement
d'offrir aux entreprises des yvelines
des années des possibilités d'accès
justement à des solutions numériques qui
pourrait qui leur permet de se
développer
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les entreprises
françaises illinois sont en retard dans
cette thématique du digital la
transparence qui ont du mérite je pense
que beaucoup d'entreprises qui sont en
retard il ya un retard à rattraper
bon maintenant je crois que tout le
monde essaye justement d'aider les
entreprises à rattraper ce retard donc
il est important aussi que les chambres
de commerce s'impliquent
d'une manière a pourtant dû justement
pour aider les entreprises à rattraper
ce retard c'est ce que nous faisons
justement et le dans le cadre du juste
dans le cadre justement de ce thé de cet
espace de coworking nous aurons des
showrooms des présentations de solutions
qui vont permettre de les aider à
évoluer et puis nous avons aussi des
conseillers numérique qui vont les aider
donc on pourra retrouver une offre assez
assez large sur place espace de
coworking également différents
conseillers qui seront présentés sérieux
power king conseillers qui seront
présents et puis des échanges aussi avec
des structures que nous accueillons des
partenaires puisque nous avons des
partenaires aussi qui qui loue des
locaux à la chambre de commerce des
structures de financement de financement
pardon qui sont présentes à la chambre
de commerce donc cet échange jeu cet
échange que l'on pourra avoir à la fois
avec des personnes qui sont dans
l'espace de corps qui ne déconseillait
des partenaires et puis nous avons aussi
des locataires depuis depuis un an la
chambre donc c'est une chambre de
commerce très ouverte open
donc open spot et est un élément
important qui va dans ce sens nous
essayons justement de créer d'avoir une
chambre de commerce qui soit la maison
des entreprises véritablement la maison
dans des entreprises parce que les
entreprises sont dans dans la chambre de
commerce et vous le disiez le rôle d'une
cci c'est d'être un petit peu un
catalyseur aussi dans dans cette
transformation digitale l' open spot
c'est l'une de ces offres mais il ya une
offre numérique digital qui est qui et
même plus large qui est proposée par la
cci fait les 18 heures telle offre
numérique de la cci à une offre
effectivement qu est porté par la
chambre de commerce paris ile-de-france
qui qui sont les digits heures et qui
vont être présentés justement dans le
cadre de l'open spot
ça c'est une autre c'est une offre qui
va développer de plus en plus à la
chambre et les digits heures offre de
justement la possibilité de voir des
solutions pour numérique au service des
entreprises
un mot sur aussi donc l' espace de
coworking on l'a dit il y aura plusieurs
possibilités des espaces en open space
mais aussi la possibilité de bénéficier
des espaces fermés semi fermée quand on
reçoit un client quand on a un rendez
vous sur place graux effectivement il ya
des salles de réunion aussi qui peuvent
être mises à disposition des salles de
réunions entre pour 10 à 15 personnes
d'accord donc c'est des espaces qui sont
mises en location dans l'espace de deux
power king à la fois des possibilités de
prendre des bureaux lorsqu'on reçoit
quelqu'un mais aussi d'organiser des
réunions sur place
et puis la possibilité aussi de
participer un centre d'événements qui
sont organisées à la chambre dans la
chambre ça permet justement de créer cet
échange est d'avoir des experts au
travers d' express et co2 de matinée qui
sont organisées de matinée thématiques
qui vont permettre justement aux chefs
d'entreprises d'être bien dans une
chambre de commerce et pour retrouver
toutes les informations les tarifs aussi
des informations sur la réservation pour
le pen spot 60,18 vous pouvez vous
rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci gérard
bacheliers d'avoir été avec nous merci à
vous ne se rappelle que vous êtes le
président de la cci
saïb line est des professionnels de la
santé et du sport mais aussi des
athlètes de haut niveau présents samedi
l'université versailles saint quentin
organisé son premier symposium sur la
prévention sport et santé c'était à
montigny le bretonneux
un rendez vous qui se veut récurrent
chaque année d'ici les jeux olympiques
2024 une première édition avec pour
thème prévenir les blessures notamment
dans la pratique du judo et du rugby des
propos recueillis par nicolas d'andré la
médecine est en train d'entrer dans une
nouvelle ère qui ait l'air de la
prévention l'action doit être mis sur la
prévention prévention à la fois des
maladies et par le sport en particulier
et prévention des récidives de maladie
chez les patients qui ont été malades
là encore grâce au sport judo s'est plus
particulièrement les genoux parce qu'on
est on est vraiment toujours en
équilibre on est sollicité par des
déplacements et puis une opposition
donc c'est vrai que souvent les
ligaments croisés sont touchés par par
une pratique de très haut niveau
également des petits traumatismes au
niveau des mains des doigts des coudes
sur des répétitions mouvement mais on
peut aussi prévenir sa part à la forme
de jeux comme a proposé c'est à dire que
au lieu chez les jeunes de partir sur
des situations où on va demander aux
joueurs d'aller sur une heure
d'entraînement pendant 20 minutes
d'aller percuter des boucliers ce qui ce
qui est pas très motivant pour les
jeunes on va plutôt essayer de partir
sur sur du jeu d'évitement du jeu de
passes dans lequel ils vont prendre
beaucoup de plaisir
voilà et ça ça permettra d'avoir
peut-être un rugby un peu plus un peu
plus intelligent est là son 2e édition
de l'open de france de golf s'est
clôturé ce dimanche victoire sur le fil
d'un suédois alexander noren c'est une
première dans l'histoire elle les
tricolores eux n'ont pas brillé le
premier français michael lorenzo vera
termine 16e un retour sur la compétition
avec miquel et demi d'euros et nicolas
dandois il est le premier suédois
soulever le trophée sur l'open de france
alexander noren 35 ans a réussi à
dompter le parcours de l'albatros avec
un score de 67 finale alors qu'il était
parti avec un déficit de sept courts
début de journée sa dixième victoire
chez les professionnels
c'est génial
j'ai été proche de gagner cette année en
amérique et j'ai été ensuite à deux
coups de la victoire de française comme
molinari à wentworth quand vous êtes si
proche vous voulez vraiment cette
victoire
et c'est un sentiment incroyable de
l'avoir aujourd'hui net les six
alexander noren l'a emporté c'est aussi
parce que les autres cadors présent
qu'elle est l'espagnol john ram a dû se
contenter d'une cinquième place son
compatriote sergio garcia terminé 8e à
égalité avec le numéro deux mondiale
justin thomass l'américain était surtout
venu pour prendre ses repères sur
l'albatros avant la ryder cup en
septembre prochain
c'est un bel endroit c'est un super
parcours une superbe ville et j'ai
vraiment aimé venir ici cette semaine du
côté les tricolores on l'attendait le
numéro un français alexander levy le
chouchou du public français
ce dernier terminera finalement une
décevante 65e place au classement
seul michael lorenzo-vera arrive à se
hisser dans le top 20 en terminant 16e
position avec une carte de 68 le
dimanche c'est toujours dans un très bon
j'ai pas non plus fini très très haut
je pense que c'est pas une
un truc à retenir par rapport aux autres
français je pense que le monde se bat
pour faire mieux que le top 20 si les
français n'ont pas su saisir leur chance
avec cette victoire sur le futur
parcours de la ryder cup le suédois
alexander noren pourrait définitivement
convaincre le staff de le prendre dans
l'équipe européenne
réponse au plus tard le 12 septembre et
la prochaine grande compétition de golf
bien sûr à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
aller dans 87 jours la ryder cup mettra
aux prises l es12 meilleurs golfeurs
américains contre le top 12 européen
pour immortaliser cette première en
france à du 25 au 30 septembre
un timbre spécial ryder cup est
disponible depuis aujourd'hui un bon
soir frédéric membres bonsoir il est le
directeur adjoint de philaposte alors
avant de parler de ce timbre philaposte
c'est une entité du groupe la poste
quelles sont ses missions a fuit la
poste alors fi la pause c'est l'entité
qui gère d'une part l'imprimerie des
timbres qui est située en dordogne près
de périgueux et qui produit l'ensemble
des tables pour le marché français et
pas seulement le marché français et puis
qui régit le programme philatélique donc
des timbres d'un usage courant
les timbres philatélique qui sont
sélectionnés chaque année on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler après vous
éditer des timbres pour l'étranger aussi
c'est pâques pour la france tout à fait
environ 300 millions de timbres cette
année seront produits pour des pays en
asie en afrique au moyen-orient et c'est
un axe de développement de l'imprimerie
que de montrer notre savoir faire en
termes d'impression de timbres sur
différents continents 300 millions de
timbres qui vont à l'étranger pour la
france et c'est combien de le marché
français c'est environ un milliard et
demi de timbres dont environ 1 milliard
qui est le tome 10 h courant celui qu'on
appelle la marianne et puis 500 millions
d'autres thèmes dont les teintes
philatélique
mais c'est ça finalement c'est le terme
classique qu'on connaît la marianne des
timbres de collection aussi qu'ils sont
qui sont imprimés par philaposte
exactement les timbres de collection
c'est ce qu'on appelle le programme
philatélique
on a environ une cinquantaine de tonnes
chaque année qui sont sélectionnés au
travers de deux demandes
donc ce sont 600 à 800 demandes chaque
année elles sont examinées filtré en
fonction de critères est ce que le thème
a déjà été fait par le passé est ce que
c'est un thème trop local un thème
national
est-ce qu'il est représentatif de
différents sujets commémoratif sportif
et c'est dans ce cadre là que sont
sélectionnés les 50 tout se passe
deux thèmes qui vont apparaître pour
l'année n + 2 puisque nous sommes déjà
en train de choisir les thèmes qui
sortiront en 2020 terre se teindre de la
ryder cup ça fait deux ans qu'il a ça
c'était il ya deux ans exactement la
demande a commencé il ya presque deux
ans elle a été acceptée ya à peu près 18
mois puis il ya un travail de
collaboration avec en l'occurrence la
fédération française de golf la ryder
cup pour pouvoir définir le visuel de ce
timbre puis ensuite la mise en
production puisque environ un million de
timbres sur la ryder cup ont été
produits pour être comme vous l'avez dit
mis en vente aujourd'hui dans l'ensemble
de la france
et puis même dès samedi dernier dans un
magasin à paris qui s'appelle le carré
d'encre qui est la boutique de
l'ensemble des philatélistes rue des
mathurins sur lequel vous pouvez en
avant-première découvrir les tam qui
sortent comme pour l'impression de
billets là l'impression la diffusion de
tintin c'est un système aussi très
contrôlées pour éviter les fraudes
alors c'est très contrôlé déjà des
l'impression et c'est un site très
sécurisé et bien évidemment les teintes
ont un certain nombre de critères de
sélection et de et de contrôle notamment
de deux pistes l'intérieur des temps
pour bien évidemment détecter tout faux
timbres donc oui c'est un peu comme les
billets de banque alors pour ce timbre
ryder cup le prix d'un euro 30 c'est à
chaque fois le même prix ou ça ça dépend
de l'édition aussi le choix a été fait
sur ce terme de choisir le tarif
mondiale solide dans la tarification il
ya des tarifs locaux européens et monde
le choix a été fait de faire un tarif
monde puisque c'était la symbolique de
la rencontre entre l'europe d'un côté
les états unis de l'autre et de pouvoir
en tant que golfeur français envoyé un
courrier et un timbre à travers le monde
donc c'est un peu le bois du golfeur par
opposition au fer ou par cinq
si on devait prendre des parallèles avec
avec le golf c'est le troisième timbre
proposé par la poste qui est consacrée
au golf
je vous propose d'écouter à ce propos
laura flessel la ministre des sports qui
étaient présentes vendredi lors de
révélation de ce timbre écouter ce
qu'elle pense à propos de ce timbre
spécial ryder cup il est très beau qui
représente vraiment l'engagement
collectif de gérer de toute une nation
de tous les acteurs publics privés du
monde du mouvement sportif de la poste
c'est vrai que on approche de la ryder
cup qui est le troisième plus grand
événement aux montres et on voit que ça
ça crée une énergie et voit
effectivement on a dévoilé le thème qui
est un partout laura flessel le dise un
timbre qui ira partout où est-ce que
c'est aussi l'objectif de ce timbre
faire connaître la ryder cup cette
compétition troisième compétition
médiatique au monde auprès des français
le golf a peut-être pas une bonne
réputation auprès des français en tout
cas elles ne connaissent peut-être pas
assez à celle golfe
ce qui est clair c'est que l'objectif de
sortir le timbre début juillet c'était
le sortir bien longtemps avant la
compétition qui aura lieu fin septembre
pour que le visuel de cette compétition
puisse circuler sur les courriers dès
cet été
le tarif international est un tarif qui
fonctionne mieux en été puisque
finalement pour les touristes étrangers
qui vont venir en france par exemple
c'est l'occasion lorsqu'il trouvant ce
timbre de pouvoir franchir du courrier
vers les états unis ou ailleurs à propos
de cette compétition donc oui en lançant
le terme 100 jours avant la compétition
l'espoir partagé et de philaposte mais
également de la fédération française de
golf et des équipes ryder cup europe
c'est bien sûr de faire parler de la
compétition dès le début il était
finalement une émulation alors en plus
de ce timbre à partir de septembre sera
proposée vous êtes venu avec un bloc en
partenariat avec la monnaie de paris
exactement
c'était une demande assez forte les
collectionneurs sont toujours très
intéressé par des opérations un tirage
plus limité le timbre du même si un
million d'exemplaires
mais c'était de faire des produits plus
d'exceptions et donc qu'ils seront comme
on le voit là c'est une maquette pour
l'instant reprise des quatre timbres que
vous avez présenté tout à l'heure et une
médaille de la monnaie de paris
de plus en plus de teindre sont
d'ailleurs réalisé sur des thématiques
communes avec la monnaie de paris
c'était le cas de deux timbres qu'on a
sorti récemment pour simone veil en même
temps qu'une pièce de la monnaie de
paris par exemple ça sera disponible à
partir de septembre une dernière
question à partir sur la philatélie
pardon est ce que les les yvelines la
volaille à cet événement sur la ryder
cup qui se déroulera au goal de 50 ans
ni vs que les les yvelines sont une
terre de philatélie est ce que il ya
beaucoup de passionnés de timbres dans
les yvelines
alors même si c'est une passion qui est
ainsi répartie nationalement cédric les
yvelines sont assez fortement
représentés et gérer plus largement
l'ouest parisien
les yvelines woodsen paris sont des
terres de philatélistes historique qui
on trouve beaucoup d'associations
philatélique dans ces départements l'a
peut-être que la présence d'un grand
magasin le car est donc dont je parlais
tout à l'heure qui facilite aussi la
découverte des produits en est la cause
merci à frédéric morin d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur adjoint de philaposte et pour
plus d'information à sur ce timbre
spécial ryder cup rendez vous sur le
site internet à qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
quatre jours de compétition pour
connaître les leaders nationaux les
yvelines accueilli ce week-end les
championnats de france de cyclisme sur
route
un retour en ile-de-france vingt ans
après linas montlhéry huit titres ont
été décernés sur les routes de
mantes-la-jolie ce dimanche c'était
l'épreuve en ligne des professionnels
masculins ambiance parmi les supporters
avec mélanie poquet et nicolas dandois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un départ matinal pour les 151
professionnelle mais leur n'a pas
refroidi les supporters et les coureurs
ce dimanche 1er juillet pour l'équipe
donc pas pour un personnellement
mais pour toute l'équipe fdj faut qu'on
garde le maillot ils sont cons si on s'y
prépare voilà allez dans la tête c'est
fait on le sait depuis quelques mois que
ça sera de bonheur donc voilà on
s'habitue on en est on s'y préparer en
amont on a essayé de suivre un peu plus
tôt que d'habitude les jours précédents
le natif de versailles couru quasiment à
domicile sur ses routes d'entraînement
dans le public du soutien celui de ses
proches
on les appelle à 25 km d'ici donc on est
devenu amis famille pour produits pour
mieux encourager au départ de 253 km
quelques uns des meilleurs du peloton
français allaient très bon la forme est
bonne aussi aux cadors de premier league
le champ pénal et dans l'arbre du
tournoi est
s'ils sont peu inespéré dans la plage
est toujours motivé à quelques jours du
départ du tour de france pour la nôtre
départ du championnat de france est
toujours une course spéciale donc je
suis content d'être ici pas donc la
jolie a vu gagner anthony roux de
l'équipe groupama fdj les coureurs sont
maintenant tournés vers le tour de
france départ le 7 juillet de vendée
avec l'été c'est le retour aussi de la
traditionnelle et apprécier fête des
loges jusqu'au 19 août les visiteurs
peuvent profiter d'attraction dans la
forêt de saint-germain-en-laye
l'événement a été inaugurée samedi
reportage de nicolas landry et tous qui
nirhy lanto 366 édition
cet été encore la fête des loges revient
d attraction sur huit hectares au coeur
de la forêt de saint germain en laye un
événement ancré dans la commune depuis
le xiième siècle avant la fête il y
avait d'abord un pèlerinage ya cet
enracinement historique qui est là elle
a une dimension aussi religieux c'était
une fête chrétienne notamment parce
qu'on célèbre tous les ans la saint
fiacre et le jour de la saint fiacre le
19 juillet cette année on a une une
messe qui est célébrée avec tous les
paroissiens de la ville sur les autos
tamponneuses avec l'évêque
c'est assez atypique mais ça fait partie
également de des traditions de cette
fête la fête des loges c'est maintenant
cette semaine de festivités et de jeu
auto tamponneuses train fantôme ou
encore tours ascensionnel mais c'est
aussi la solidarité
à chaque édition son association mise à
l'honneur cette année
il s'agit d' autour des williams elle
aide les malades du syndrome de williams
buren une maladie génétique orpheline
une grande partie des recettes de la
soirée d'ouverture a été reversée on a
récolté une somme gigantesque 27000
euros 27100 84 euros pour être très
précis et 700 bêtes intégralement
affectés pour nos familles pour créer
des rencontres c'est là où on peut
échanger c'est là on peut pas laisser on
peut s'entraider
donc on va organiser une très grosse
fête pour parler et pas les seuls
aspects médicaux si le beau temps se
maintient la fréquentation devrait être
au rendez vous la fête des loges c'est
juste que
19 août à saint germain en laye côte
on referme ce journal avec des images
encore qui sentent bon l'été samedi la
commune de villepreux a organisé pour la
toute première fois une colo run au
programme un parcours de 3 km avec des
obstacles pneus barrière ou encore de la
paille à chaque passage les la centaine
de participants était arrosé avec de la
poudre de couleur bleu rose ou jaune on
écoute les réactions au micro de nicolas
landry très sympa d'accord ça très cool
très coloré ouai c'est trop bien
génial j'en ai vu de toutes les couleurs
ils nous ont pas rater ça c'est sûr
voyez les obstacles étaient bien
sportive voile et les bottes de paille
surtout a grimpé à redescendre avec le
temps qui fait n'était pas évident
c'était rigolo et surtout enfin c'était
pas une course toute simple c'était
un an de plus
monthey et dans un instant ne manquez
pas le 7-8 sport présentée par michael
et demi d'euros c'est la fin de ce
journal belle soirée excellente semaine
sur tv 78
[Musique]